am Ende des Tages des Donald Trump
wieder da wo er sich am wohlsten fühlt
in seinem Anwesenden Florida vor treuen
Anhängern ihre Verehrung ist sein
Lebenselixier weiterhin beschimpft der
Angeklagte Trump den New Yorker Richter
als Trump Huster und behauptet seine
Gegner wollten ihn mit der Anklage
ausschalten
jetzt wollen diese linksradikalen
verrückten mit der Justiz die Wahlen
beeinflussen das dürfen wir nicht
zulassen
Stunden zuvor Trump stellt sich in New
York muss beim Staatsanwalt erscheinen
und seine Fingerabdrücke abgeben so
kennt man ihn nicht ernst ist der
Ex-Präsident auf dem Weg in den
Gerichtssaal kleinlaut hier ist er nicht
Herr des Geschehens sichtliches
Unbehagen in 34 Fällen habe er
betrügerisch Geschäftsunterlagen
gefälscht um kriminelles Verhalten zu
verbergen drei schweige Geldzahlungen um
vor der Präsidentschaftswahl 2016
schädliche Informationen vor den Wählern
zu verheimlichen so die
Staatsanwaltschaft
heute sind wir unserer Verantwortung
gerecht geworden dass jeder vor dem
Gesetz gleich ist weder viel Geld noch
viel Macht ändern diesen beständigen
amerikanischen Grundsatz
der Angeklagte Donald Trump plädierte
auf nicht schuldig und kam anschließend
ohne Auflagen frei Trump oder Tod
draußen auf den Straßen New Yorks ist
Zirkus die Botschaften plakativ die
Polizei stellt sicher dass es ruhig
bleibt die Anhänger Trumps und seine
Gegner werden durch Absperrungen
getrennt inhaltlich sind sie noch weiter
auseinander als die paar Meter Stein
wir hoffen dass er endlich zur
Rechenschaft gezogen wird
dieses Verfahren ist ja nur die Spitze
des Eisbergs wenn es erstmal um
Wahlbetrug geht dann wird das ein sehr
viel schwerwiegender Fall
sie tun alles um ihn zu stoppen aber er
wird nicht aufgeben und wir auch nicht
und er muss auch nicht aufgeben denn
auch als Angeklagter kann Donald Trump
für die Präsidentschaft kandidieren